CBS News chief white Washington
correspondent and Face the Nation anchor
John Dickerson is in Washington John
good morning let's start with that news
just out this morning a crackdown inside
the White House led by the chief of
staff John Kelly as the press secretary
putting out a statement that the
security and integrity of the technology
systems at the White House is paramount
no more personal devices for anybody
guests or staff well it is sort of
closing the barn door after the horse is
over them over the hill I mean this book
is out the paint the picture that it
paints of the White House the sort of
pre John Kelly White House it will be
the source of discussion for weeks and
also you know you can try to crack down
anybody with teenagers knows this you
can try to crack down but people who
want to speak will find ways to speak
and why do they want to speak because in
a White House that is having trouble
functioning and lots of white houses do
this one is a bit has a particular
challenge but as people who get shut out
and who feel disgruntled they seek the
way to get their information out into
the world and they don't have to do that
through digital devices they can use
telephones or in-person meetings or all
kinds of other different ways there are
a lot of gossipy salacious details in
this book but what's the significance do
you think in terms of the substance of
how this White House is operating well
that's exactly the right question
there's gonna be a lot of back-and-forth
on little tiny details and and but the
big picture here is a picture of a white
house that is chaotic of a president
whose impulses whipsaw the White House
of a lot of backstabbing front stabbing
and and this was during a period where
the White House was saying it was a
well-oiled machine where everybody was
saying things were working perfectly
we've then seen in the reaction to the
book from the president and his staff
the kind of over-the-top statements that
sort of affirm the underlying story and
also there's a context here this is not
the first time that people have reported
about chaos inside the White House so it
comes in that larger context so while as
you say there are a lot of salacious
details the thing to step back and look
at is this is a White House this is the
same office Ronald Reagan had that FDR
had that that is being run in an
has had episodes that are really out of
keeping with previous White House but
the other question here John is how much
has the White House then changed pre
Kelly versus post John Kelly well that's
exactly right and clearly John Kelly has
established some order lots and lots of
people have been fired or let go or
pushed out including Steve Bannon so
there is a more shipshape operation in
the White House but one of the things
we're talking about is how much did the
president talk to Michael Wolf how much
was he operating and does he operate on
his own timetable where which nobody can
control and we saw recently the
president given an interview within New
York Times that was basically his own
decision and that his staff didn't know
about so while there is more there is
more organization there is still the
person at the center of it who is
impulsive that's how that what helped
him get elected but it's also what
causes a lot of these problems Jon do
you think there are practical
implications as far as Robert Muller's
investigation goes Steve Bannon is
quoted in this book saying some of the
behavior on the part of the president's
top aides was treasonous well
politically the fact that he says that
is dangerous because the president are
not dangerous but it's it's not good for
the president because he's been spending
so much time trying to undermine the
investigation here you have Steve ban
and basically saying this meeting with
somebody who said they had dirt coming
from the Russian government was
treasonous so it gives validation to
something the president in the White
House has been trying to undermine in
terms of what the Special Counsel is
doing he's got lots of interviews going
on with people who were in the room so I
don't think this book really affects
that he's working on his own timetable
all right John Dickerson thank you so
much